I think what's different about Peter
Parker what's different about spider-man
is Peter Parker and Peter Parker is a
kid like and he grew up and like we all
did he had to do chores and he had to
you know make money and he had trouble
talking to girls I mean I know I can
identify with that in particular but he
he was he's not a billionaire he's not
an alien he's a kid and and that's what
makes him so relatable and I think to me
the domestic part of that drama was as
important if not more important than
everything else in the movie and and you
know there's a scene with Sally Field
and where Peter comes home and and you
know he's got bruises on his face and
and I really like doing that scene
because it was first of all it was Sally
and and Andrew and I was like what did i
do right in a past life to work with
these people it was amazing but there
was it just felt like seeing that it
didn't feel like a superhero movie and I
felt like that was an important thing
for me I didn't want to think in those
terms I wanted to thank as you say in
melodrama and and just about the
personal conflicts that would arise and
what we really happen in that situation
if you if you were a guardian of a kid
who was clearly troubled and came home
with bruises on his face you'd be
terrified it would break your heart and
he's like and he's trying to do the
right thing and she's trying to do the
right thing and there's this wonderful
interesting I think very relatable
conflict but then there's also little
innocent scenes like them in the hallway
and those to me are you know movies
ultimately our social experience and you
have to really connect and care about
the characters and I think those are the
moments where I think movies really come
alive and the action and the spectacle
and the thrill that doesn't mean
anything if you don't care about the
people like the kid behind the mask and
I wanted again I wanted to I wanted to
get away from the idea of big movie I
wanted to make it small and intimate I
wanted the characters in the actors to
feel safe and I wanted them to feel like
they guy wanted to feel spontaneous and
natural and not burdened by you know a
big schedule or effects or anything like
that and and so andrew is a incredibly
highly trained very good
did actor I mean he's brilliant if
you've seen Red Riding or or the social
network or boy you you know the caliber
of actor that he is indefinite salesman
or a Death of a Salesman I saw ya in New
York I mean he has a sixth gear which is
just extraordinary and and he can do
intensity and lean into drama very well
and Emma is a as a light she's a
wonderful actor but comes from a very
different background she does you know
did a lot of improvisation
improvisational comedy she did a lot of
those you know Judd Apatow movies and
and is really light on her feet and when
they came together what was interesting
is they're very the kind of actors that
are that are very spontaneous and they
love to improvise and you know she
brought out a lightness in him and she
and he brought out something I think
deeper in her and together there was
just this multiplier effect and I really
was about me getting out of the way you
know I I wish I could take credit for it
but they're just they're magic together
I love I remember we were shooting that
scene and I would like I was I it's it's
a simple thing and sometimes you're not
aware of it when you're watching it but
I feel like there was you fell in love
with them at that moment I know I did I
was like I felt like there was a real
and i was i was very happy to be able to
get to be given the freedom to like
diverge from the script when i wanted to
because it was about the feeling i think
it's an interesting thing like this is
something that I've learned you know
there's and it's obvious when I say it
but there is a language like there are
certain kinds of scripts work you know
you're developing a river like rhythm
like a you know an aaron sorkin script
or many brilliant scripts from over the
years and then there is there's a there
is something else like if you can't own
into your tree like tune into a certain
kind of behavior like that's what was
great about android emma is I feel like
they got underneath everything in it and
it seems to become acting and it became
behavior and there was a you can sense
the way they move and the way they look
at each other in the eye contact and the
awareness in those moments and it
becomes
it becomes something different and it's
really it's a testament to their to
their gifts I think there's a reason why
spider-man has been around for 50 years
and and these comic book heroes are and
I don't I wish I knew exactly what it
was I don't know what it is but there's
there's something it's it's it's I think
that there's again like there's a
melodrama I thought the heart of a lot
of these these characters I mean you're
a big comic book fan you think you know
that the people are starting to
appreciate just how much of a genius
Stan Lee is I mean he was he is he's
extraordinary and like he's still I mean
he's still coming up with characters and
stories and and it's it's very
impressive and humbling to see someone
like that but there's there's a
complexity and nuance that you find in
comic books that I think people are
starting to realize the power of